आपको इन्वेस्ट करना चाहिए और यह बहुत
जरूरी होता है। यह कहते तो सब हैं बट कोई
अच्छे से यह नहीं बताता कि क्यों। क्यों
इन्वेस्ट करना जरूरी है? तो चलिए इस
एपिसोड वन ऑफ बेसिक्स ऑफ स्टॉक मार्केट
में समझते हैं कि क्यों? अगर आप इन्वेस्ट
नहीं करते हो तो आपके पैसे का एग्जैक्टली
क्या होता है? इसको समझने के लिए वरुण की
हेल्प लेते हैं और कुछ अजमशंस करते हैं।
वरुण 25 साल का है और 50 पे रिटायर होना
चाहता है। मतलब वो सिर्फ 25 साल के लिए ही
काम करना चाहता है। उसकी सैलरी ₹00 है और
महीने के एक्सपेंसेस हैं ₹00। मतलब हर
महीने वो ₹00 बचाता है। उसका एंप्लयर काफी
काइंड है और वो उसे हर साल 10% का सैलरी ह
भी दे देता है। कॉस्ट ऑफ लिविंग साल भर हर
साल से 8% बढ़ती है और उसके एक्सपेंसेस भी
फिक्स्ड हैं। कोई एक्सपेंसेस वो और इससे
ज्यादा फोर्स ही नहीं करता। एंड ये 20,000
का बैलेंस वो और कहीं भी इन्वेस्ट नहीं
करता। बस अपने पास एक कैश की फॉर्म में
रखता है। क्या लगता है? 25 साल में बिना
इन्वेस्ट किए कितना पैसा इकट्ठा हो गया
होगा? लगभग 3.27 करोड़ के आसपास। बुरा
नहीं है ना? बट इसका मतलब है कि उन 25
सालों में वरुण के एक्सपेंसेस सेम है।
मतलब वो अपना लाइफस्टाइल चेंज नहीं कर
सकता। उसकी ख्वाहिशें जैसे कार खरीदना, घर
खरीदना या फिर वेकेशन पे जाना एक्सट्रा यह
सब भी अचीव करना मुश्किल होगा। और अगर 50
पे रिटायर होने के लिए शायद यह ₹3 करोड़
कम पड़ जाए या सिर्फ 7 आठ साल में ही खत्म
हो जाए तो क्या सिर्फ इतना काफी है? लेकिन
अगर वरुण ने इन्वेस्ट किया होता तो ओवर द
पीरियड ऑफ ये 25 साल वरुण के पास लगभग
9.36 करोड़ इकट्ठे हो जाते। 3x अमाउंट
होती है। बट एक चीज ये है कि इसमें हमने
अभी भी टैक्सेस को अकाउंट नहीं किया है।
पर फिर भी आपको फेयर आईडिया तो मिल ही गया
होगा कि व्हाई टू इन्वेस्ट। पहला रीज़ है
टू फाइट इनफ्लेशन। कॉस्ट ऑफ लिविंग हर साल
से बढ़ती है। आई मीन अब आपको अपने पेरेंट्स
का एग्जांपल तो याद ही होगा। जब वो कहते
थे कि हम स्कूल जाते थे तो स्कूल की फीस
₹25 थी। हमारे टाइम पर 25,000 है और हो
सकता है आने वाले टाइम में हमारे बच्चों
के लिए 500 या उससे भी ज्यादा हो सकती है।
दूसरा कारण टू इन्वेस्ट है टू हैव बेटर
[संगीत] स्टैंडर्ड ऑफ लिविंग। अगर आप
लाइफस्टाइल अपग्रेड करना चाहते हो तो उसके
लिए भी यू नीड [संगीत] टू इन्वेस्ट। और
तीसरा है टू क्रिएट वेल्थ। खुद इतना काम
करते हो तो आपके लिए आपका पैसा क्यों ना
काम करे और यह वेल्थ हेल्प करेगी टू जनरेट
कॉर्पस फॉर योर रिटायरमेंट, मैरिज,
एजुकेशन एंड आपके बच्चों की शादी भी।
बाइंग फैंसी कार एंड और क्या नहीं। अब जब
आपको समझ आ गया है कि इन्वेस्ट करना जरूरी
है, तो अब आप सोच रहे होंगे कि कितने पैसे
से इन्वेस्टमेंट को शुरू किया जा सकता है।
अगर कुछ कॉमन बेसिक इन्वेस्टमेंट्स और
उनके मिनिमम रिक्वायरमेंट टू इन्वेस्ट की
बात करूं तो स्टॉक्स में आपको उतना पैसा
चाहिए जितना कि स्टॉक प्राइस है।
म्यूच्यूल फंड जनरली ₹500 से शुरू हो जाते
हैं मिनिमम इन्वेस्टमेंट लेकिन कई
म्यूच्यूल फंड्स में ₹10 से भी शुरू कर
सकते हो। पीपीएफ का मिनिमम रिक्वायरमेंट
है ₹500। एफडी डिपेंड करता है
इंस्टीट्यूशन से इंस्टीट्यूशन लेकिन वो भी
लगभग 500 से 1000 के बीच में। मतलब बहुत
सारा कैपिटल तो नहीं चाहिए टू स्टार्ट बट
यू नीड टू बी कंसिस्टेंट। इंपॉर्टेंट यही
है कि स्टार्ट चाहे छोटे से करो लेकिन ओवर
द पीरियड ऑफ़ टाइम अपनी इन कंट्रीब्यूशनंस
को इनक्रीस करो। अब इन्वेस्ट क्यों करना
है एंड कितने पैसे चाहिए टू इन्वेस्ट?
इसका आंसर तो मिल गया। अब क्वेश्चन आता है
कि इन्वेस्टमेंट करना शुरू कब करना है?
इसका आंसर तो बहुत ही सिंपल है। आज या फिर
एएसएपी मतलब जितना जल्दी हो सके उतना
जल्दी। क्यों? यह डाटा देखो। अनुषा बेशक
30 की है और सिर्फ 10,000 इन्वेस्ट कर रही
है हर महीने। और ऐसा वो 30 सालों के लिए
करने वाली है। [संगीत] राजेश और सिमरन
सोचते हैं कि लाइफ में शुरुआत में थोड़ा
फन कर लेते हैं। बाद में बहुत टाइम होगा
टू इन्वेस्ट। आल्सो वो यह भी कहते हैं कि
बाद में ज्यादा पैसे डाल देंगे
इन्वेस्टमेंट के लिए और वो अपनी
इन्वेस्टमेंट जर्नी की शुरुआत करते हैं
20,000 और 30,000 टिल 20 इयर्स एंड 30
इयर्स रेस्पेक्टिवली। अब आप देखो कि तीनों
ने इंडिविजुअली कितना अमाउंट इकट्ठा किया।
इसे कहते हैं पावर ऑफ कंपाउंडिंग। एंड द
फैक्ट इज कि कंपाउंडिंग का बेस्ट फ्रेंड
इज टाइम नॉट मनी। फंडा सिंपल है। रादर देन
स्टार्टिंग लेट एंड इन्वेस्टिंग मोर
शुरुआत जल्दी करो चाहे थोड़ी अमाउंट से ही
करो। बट इनिशियली क्या होता है?
कंपाउंडिंग का मैजिक दिखता नहीं है। बट
इसका मतलब ये नहीं [संगीत] कि होता नहीं
है। जैसे जब हम प्लांट लगाते हैं तो ऐसा
नहीं है कि प्लांट ग्रो नहीं कर रहा जमीन
के अंदर करता है। बट हमें इसकी ग्रोथ काफी
बाद में दिखाई देती [संगीत] है। ऐसा ही
कंपाउंडिंग के साथ भी होता है। बस थोड़ा
पेशेंट रहना पड़ेगा। सी अर्ली स्टार्ट
करने का एक और बेनिफिट यह है कि आप जल्दी
मार्केट्स के बारे में सीखते हो [संगीत]
कि मार्केट्स कैसे रिएक्ट करती हैं या फिर
स्पेसिफिक इवेंट्स जैसे इलेक्शन, बजट,
वॉर, इंटरेस्ट रेट अनाउंसमेंट्स एक्सट्रा
के दिन मार्केट में क्या होता है। एंड
इवेंचुअली ये आपको बेटर डिसिशनंस लेने में
मदद करता है। और ये सब आप अपनी लो कैपिटल
के साथ सीखते हो। और जब आपकी कैपिटल
इनक्रीस होगी विद टाइम आपकी नॉलेज अबाउट
मार्केट्स और भी बेटर हो जाएगी। एंड यू मे
कम अप विद बेटर इन्वेस्टमेंट स्ट्रेटजीस।
अब आते हैं अगले क्वेश्चन पर कि कहां
इन्वेस्ट करना होता है? तो इसका आंसर है
एसेट में। अब ये एसेट क्या होता है? एसेट
बेसिकली इज समथिंग दैट यू होल्ड जिसकी
करंट एंड फ्यूचर में कोई मॉनिटरी वैल्यू
हो जिसको आप कैश में कन्वर्ट कर सकते हो।
फॉर एग्जांपल आपके पेरेंट्स का घर एक एसेट
है जिसकी करंट एंड फ्यूचर दोनों में
मॉनिटरी वैल्यू है। जब आप इसे बेचते हो तो
वो हाउस को कैश में कन्वर्ट किया जा सकता
है। ये एसेट्स ब्रॉडली चार एसेट कैटेगरीज
में डिवाइडेड होते हैं। गोल्ड, रियलस्टेट,
इक्विटी एंड फिक्स्ड इनकम। सबसे पहले
गोल्ड की बात करें तो गोल्ड एक एंशिएंट
एसेट है। यह रेयर है। लिमिटेड सप्लाई में
है और ग्लोबल क्राइसिस और इनफ्लेशन के
टाइम पर और भी इंपॉर्टेंट हो जाता है। आप
फिजिकल गोल्ड, एसजीबीस या गोल्ड ईटीएफ के
थ्रू इन्वेस्ट कर सकते हो। दूसरा एसेट है
रियलस्टेट। रियलस्टेट मतलब इन्वेस्टिंग इन
लैंड या फिर प्रॉपर्टी। इसमें वैल्यू
एप्रिसिएशन और रेंटल इनकम दोनों मिल सकती
है। लेकिन कैपिटल ज्यादा चाहिए होगी।
लिक्विडिटी कम होती है और इसे ईजीली बेचना
आसान नहीं होता। इसलिए आरईआईटीस दैट इज
रियलस्टेट इन्वेस्टमेंट ट्रस्ट आए जिससे
छोटे अमाउंट से भी रियलस्टेट एक्सपोज़र मिल
सकता है। तीसरा एसेट है इक्विटी जिसे
हमारा मतलब है हिस्सेदारी मतलब ओनरशिप।
मतलब जब आप किसी कंपनी में इक्विटी के
थ्रू इन्वेस्ट करते हो तो आप उस कंपनी के
हिस्सेदार या फिर उतने पोर्शन के ओनर बन
जाते हो। और जैसे एक बिजनेसमैन का अपने
बिजनेस या फिर अपनी कंपनी के लिए रिस्क
ज्यादा होता है वैसे ही क्योंकि आप भी एक
सर्टेन अमाउंट के लिए ओनर हो इसलिए आपका
भी रिस्क ज्यादा होगा। बेशक इक्विटी में
इन्वेस्ट करने से रिस्क ज्यादा होता है
लेकिन हायर द रिस्क हायर द रिवॉर्ड। दैट
इज व्हाई इक्विटी एज एन एसेट हेल्प करता
है टू बिल्ड वेल्थ ओवरटाइम। इसलिए वी शुड
इन्वेस्ट इन इक्विटीज़। इक्विटीज में
इन्वेस्ट करने के तीन तरीके हैं। वन इज
इन्वेस्टिंग इन इक्विटी वाया म्यूच्यूल
फंड। सेकंड इज वाया बाया स्टक्स एंड थर्ड
इज वाया ईपीएफ्स। लास्टली आता है फिक्स्ड
इनकम इंस्ट्रूमेंट्स। अनलाइक इक्विटीज
व्हेयर यू बिकम अ पार्ट ओनर ऑफ द कंपनीज़
फिक्स्ड इनकम इंस्ट्रूमेंट्स आर लाइक डे।
मतलब आप किसी कंपनी या एंटिटी को लोन देते
हो जिस पर आपको इन रिटर्न इंटरेस्ट मिलता
है। यह इंटरेस्ट क्वार्टरली, सेमी एनुअली
या फिर एनुअली मिल सकता है। जो भी कैपिटल
आप इन्वेस्ट करते हो एट द एंड ऑफ़ द
इन्वेस्टमेंट पीरियड वापस कर दी जाती है
और इसे मैच्योरिटी पीरियड कहते हैं। एज़
कंपेयर टू इक्विटीज़, इसमें रिस्क कम होता
है, लेकिन लेसर द रिस्क, लेसर द रिटर्न। अ
फ्यू एग्जांपल ऑफ फिक्स्ड इनकम
इंस्ट्रूमेंट्स आर जैसे कि बैंक की
फिक्स्ड डिपॉजिट्स, बॉन्ड इशूड बाय द
गवर्नमेंट ऑफ इंडिया, बॉन्ड्स इशूड बाय
गवर्नमेंट रिलेटेड टू एजेंसीज सच एज GEL,
एनएचएआई एक्सट्रा बॉन्ड्स इशूड बाय
कॉर्पोरेट्स जैसे कि Tata, Bajaj,
Reliance, adानी एक्सट्रा। अब बैलेंस
बिटवीन इनकम, [संगीत] स्पेंडिंग एंड
इन्वेस्टिंग। यह समझना जरूरी है। अब जब आप
इन्वेस्टमेंट क्या, कितना, कब, कैसे यह
सीख गए हो, लेकिन अगर आपके मन में यह बात
है कि उन पैसों से मुझे इन्वेस्ट करने के
अलावा अपनी डिजायर्स या ख्वाहिशें पूरी
करनी है और नीड्स मतलब जरूरत के लिए भी तो
पैसे चाहिए तो सब इन्वेस्ट ही करना पड़ेगा
क्या? नहीं। आप अपनी इन्वेस्टमेंट,
डिजायर्स [संगीत] और नीड्स तीनों को
बैलेंस कर सकते हो। शायद आपने 50 30 रूल
के बारे में सुना होगा। 50% आपकी नीड्स के
लिए, 30% आपकी वांट्स के लिए और 20% आपकी
इन्वेस्टमेंट्स के लिए। बैलेंस करने के
लिए आपको इन तीन कैटेगरीज में डिवाइड करना
है। पर यही परसेंटेज में करना जरूरी नहीं
है। क्योंकि अगर आपकी मंथली सैलरी 500 है
तो रूल के हिसाब से 25,000 नीड्स के लिए,
15,000 वांट्स के लिए और 10,000
इन्वेस्टमेंट्स के लिए। सही है ना? पर
आपकी नीड्स 25,000 से ज्यादा भी तो हो
सकती हैं और शायद वांट्स के लिए सिर्फ
5,000 ही चाहिए हो। इसीलिए आप चाहो तो
10,000 वांट्स के लिए 15,000
इन्वेस्टमेंट्स के लिए भी कर सकते हो या
फिर 3,000 नीड्स के लिए और 10,000 वांट्स
और 10,000 इन्वेस्टमेंट्स भी कर सकते हो।
इट इज पर्सनल फाइनेंस। हर इंडिविजुअल के
लिए डायनामिक्स डिफरेंट हो सकते हैं।
व्हाट इज इंपॉर्टेंट इज कि आप
इन्वेस्टमेंट्स के लिए प्रोविजन बनाओ।
लाइफ में अर्ली स्टार्ट करो। वो करना
जरूरी है। फिर चाहे आप 2500 से ही क्यों
नहीं अपनी इन्वेस्टमेंट जर्नी की शुरुआत
[संगीत] करते। सो हियर द फंडा दैट हेल्प्स
मी इज कि जैसे ही मेरी मंथली सैलरी आती है
सबसे पहले मैं उसमें से इन्वेस्टमेंट्स के
लिए पैसे अलग करती हूं। एंड उसके बाद
जितना भी अमाउंट बचता है डिपेंडिंग अपॉन
सिचुएशंस कि मेरी नीड्स कितनी है या फिर
बॉन्ड्स कितनी है वो उसमें डिवाइड हो जाता
है। मतलब मेरे एक्सपेंसेस में डिवाइड हो
जाता है। अब ये एक्सपेंसेस कैन बी एनीथिंग
मंथली ग्रोसरी या फिर स्विगी Zomato के
बिल बिजली का खर्चा लोन ईएमआई या फिर
बाइंग फोन एक्सट्रा। [संगीत] सो इट इज
आइडियल कि आप अपने डिजायर्स को पूरा करने
से पहले इन्वेस्ट करें और जो कुछ बच जाता
है उसके बाद वह आप स्पेंड कर सकते हैं।
लेकिन यही अगर मैं पहले अपने एक्सपेंसेस
को पूरा करूं और टुवर्ड्स द एंड ऑफ़ द मंथ
इन्वेस्ट करूं तो बहुत ज्यादा हायर चांसेस
हैं कि शायद मेरा कैपिटल ही खत्म हो जाए
और मैं इन्वेस्ट ही ना कर पाऊं। आई विल
बिकम इनकंसिस्टेंट विद माय इन्वेस्टमेंट
एंड कंपाउंडिंग का पूरा बेनिफिट लेने के
लिए कंसिस्टेंसी बहुत जरूरी होती है। सो
रादर देन फॉलोइंग दिस फार्मूला कि इनकम
में से पहले एक्सपेंसेस के खर्चे निकाले
और फिर जो बचा सेविंग्स या इन्वेस्टमेंट
यू शुड फॉलो दिस फार्मूला। इनकम में से
सबसे पहले सेविंग्स और इन्वेस्टमेंट्स के
लिए निकालो पैसे और जो बचा वो एक्सपेंस।
अब जल्दी से समझते हैं कुछ चीजें जो आपको
ध्यान में रखनी चाहिए। सबसे पहले हम इसलिए
इन्वेस्ट करते हैं ताकि अपना फाइनेंसियल
फ्यूचर सिक्योर कर सकें। दूसरा लॉन्ग टर्म
में इनफ्लेशन को बीट करने के लिए आपको
इक्विटी में इन्वेस्ट करना चाहिए। तीसरा
एक अच्छी इन्वेस्टमेंट प्रैक्टिस यही कहती
है कि आपके पोर्टफोलियो में डिफरेंट एसेट
क्लासेस होने चाहिए। चौथा स्मॉल अमाउंट से
शुरू करो पर जल्दी शुरू करो। और पांचवा
कंपाउंडिंग का बेस्ट फ्रेंड टाइम है ना कि
मनी। इन्वेस्टिंग सिर्फ पैसा कमाने का
तरीका नहीं है। यह अपने फ्यूचर को सिक्योर
करने का तरीका भी है। अगले एपिसोड में हम
बात करेंगे कि स्टॉक मार्केट होता क्या
है? तो मिलते हैं अगले एपिसोड में। तब तक
के लिए हैप्पी इन्वेस्टिंग।
ये